israel and the palestinian territories
are going up in flames
after years of relative peace during the
trump administration but do not worry
because president biden has things under
control he has sent his spokesman out
to kindly and politely tell people to
please
de-escalate since last week he has
directed his team to engage intensively
with senior israeli and palestinian
officials as well as leaders throughout
the middle east
his team is communicating a clear and
consistent message
in support of de-escalation and that is
our primary focus
that's good that's what does it that's
what brings peace to the middle east is
a clear and consistent message from the
team of the president
to de-escalate even though the
president's own messaging
on his support for israel's enemies has
been a little bit
inconsistent which has probably led us
to this very
very moment probably not going to be
able to breathe easy in that part of the
world
for a few years i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from lisa gentile
is being heavily censored that's the
name
the comment is giving immoral people
the liberty to act immorally makes the
world a worse place yes of course that's
true
it's not even liberty the idea this is
just what the libs and the squishes say
liberty is
where they say that you know if you
don't allow
transvestites to jiggle in front of
babies and toddlers you know
that's depriving americans of their
liberty and you think i don't think
james madison
quite had that in mind when he was when
he was writing the constitution i'm not
sure that's exactly what thomas
jefferson was thinking about
in the declaration of independence what
is going on
in israel i don't know how much time do
we have we could
we could be here for a very long time a
lot of news outlets
are going really really really in depth
on exactly what started the conflict and
the left-wing outlets are saying the
israelis started this and the
right-wing outlets are saying it was the
palestinian arabs
and it was because of this and it was
because of that and you could spend a
whole lot of time going back through the
millennia
to to find the origin of of this
particular conflict
for our purposes what is relevant today
is the timing why is this breaking out
right now
why were things relatively cool under
the trump administration but now they've
gotten a lot hotter
under the biden administration it's
because of two competing approaches to
the middle east
when john kerry was secretary of state
before he was gallivanting all over the
world trying to stop the sun monster
john kerry said that there is no way
to bring peace to the middle east
without first solving
the palestinian problem what is the
palestinian problem well you got this
country
israel which is created in 1948 and
you've got
arabs that are in the region and then
you've got
national borders being said all around
and then you've got
this group of people that the other
countries don't want and that are
holding out hope that they can get rid
of israel entirely
and this has created violence and and
violence has ebbed and flowed over the
years why
again i there is no reason to go
any more in depth on that that way lies
madness
the the thing that matters for us right
now is why were things relatively
peaceful under trump
and why were they why are they getting
more violent under biden
because donald trump sent a clear
message he said the united states is not
going to tolerate attacks
on the existence of israel we're not
going to give
money to people who hate us in the
region
and we're not going to side with iran
why is this well very famously i
remember seeing them when i was
when i was 11 years old the image is on
september 11th
of palestinian arabs dancing in the
streets if you want the support of the
united states
it's not a good idea to dance in the
streets and celebration
when the world trade center is attacked
so
there but even beyond the palestinian
arabs there are
lots of places in this region that don't
like us very much notably iran
the democrats strategy on the middle
east was
suck up to iran and suck up to the
palestinian arabs
and if you focus on the palestinian
issue that will solve the middle east
the right took a completely different
approach donald trump said john kerry
you're wrong you don't need to solve
this palestinian issue you're not going
to solve this palestinian issue so we're
going to go directly to the actual
nation states in the middle east because
don't forget palestine is not a country
it's that country east of wakanda and
left of narnia right it's not there is
no
nation state there called palestine so
go to the other places and you'll get
peace deals this is what happened
and iran is a big issue here the obama
administration biden want to send
pallets of cash to iran
the trump administration kills iran's
top general
right different friends different allies
different approach to the middle east
which one worked out better we we have
the data
we've got the evidence things were much
more stable
much more peaceful under trump but that
is not stopping democrats
from going back to the same old failed
strategy
bernie sanders tweets that the united
states must call for an immediate
ceasefire and an end to provocative and
illegal settlement activity
and we must also recommit to working
with israelis and palestinians
to finally end this conflict i think
most people
are going to first of all they're going
to read this tweet and say that bernie
sanders is blaming israel here right
uh okay but they're gonna they're gonna
read this tweet and they're gonna say
what do i care what do i care as an
american about israel
and palestine and the middle east why do
we have to be there at all what is the
point of this why is our foreign policy
dominated
by this one region of the world and they
have a good point
the american foreign policy should be
pretty simple do what is in the interest
of the united states
right seems simple enough now this gets
complicated because
we are involved in lots of world affairs
and we have
alliances and we are dependent on
certain places and
we it matters to us if one power gets
too big and we want to suppress other
powers so
i'm not saying it's as simple as put
your head in the sand and hope that
everything is okay in the middle east
but if our foreign policy is to do what
is in the interest of the united states
then it would seem very much to be in
our interest
to keep things relatively stable over
there without having to send troops
without having to really get involved in
any wars
when wars break out people have to start
taking sides people have to start
getting involved
and the fact is the simple fact is that
the policy of
legitimizing the palestinian nation
state
led to more violence dragged america
into this issue much much further
and the policy of basically ignoring the
palestinian
palestinian claims for a nation state
and just going directly to our other
friends and allies in the middle east
going to other
arab states in the region and saying hey
make peace don't be a jerk
keep things calm we're going to be back
over here on the other side of the
atlantic
that seemed to work out pretty well so
perhaps we should do
more of that but of course joe biden
the liberal establishment the broad sort
of liberal
imperialist foreign policy types they
don't want that
they don't seem to want that at all big
big takeaway from what's going on in
israel right now
very important to be able to defend
yourself it is pretty amazing to watch
you're seeing rockets going into israel
and then israel just
popping them off just doesn't doesn't
matter israel's iron dome
strategy is pretty amazing it's just
they're they're a very well defended
country now nations are not the only
entities that have the right to defend
themselves individuals have the right to
defend themselves
as well senator cruz made this point
yesterday uh senator cruz was in a
hearing on gun control
and the libs were making such
disingenuous arguments about how look we
don't want to take your guns we just
what we want to do is track your guns we
want to know where they are but we're
not going to take them
but we want to know exactly what guns
you have but we're not going to come
take them and we need to know exactly
where you have them but we're definitely
not going to go
steal your guns and senator cruz knocked
that argument down
democrats don't want to address the
consistent proven empirical failure of
gun
control laws they don't work and they
make crime
worse but they also want to scapegoat
law-abiding citizens
the hobbyists who make home homemade
guns who are not committing crimes
they want to scapegoat them but the real
issue is in something chairman
blumenthal made several
references to he referred to these guns
as untraceable
and that term was meant to be ominous
that's what this is all about the
democrats on this committee
want to trace every firearm in america
they want a registry of every firearm in
america they want a government list of
what guns they are
there are who owns them how many they
own them and inevitably when you see
countries enact
registries of firearms the next step is
confiscation and numerous democrats on
this committee
have advocated for confiscating firearms
of course this is obviously true if you
believe that democrats want to trace
your guns they want to know exactly how
many you have they want to know exactly
where you keep them
but they're not interested in taking
them then i have got a bridge in
brooklyn to sell
you so senator cruz hits that point he
also hit an important point at the top
of that i don't know if you caught it
which is he addressed this issue of the
ghost guns you're going to hear a lot
about this
on leftist media they're going to say
that there's this issue of ghost guns
what are ghost guns these guns that
people make themselves
and the ghost guns they're a really big
problem we got to stop the ghost guns
there is zero evidence that ghost guns
are involved in crimes ever
there's who for people i suppose who
do not who are not involved in firearms
who do not
know people who are firearms hobbyists
the people who make ghost guns are
kind of nerdy gun types who are just
really interested in this who
in my experience and i think the data
bear this out are
the most law-abiding people in the
country on the issue of guns
they know exactly what the rules are
they follow them meticulously they're
very responsible
with their firearms and cruz is saying
this is a completely
fake issue that democrats are pushing
because they want to take away your guns
i have to i have to give senator cruz
credit i don't just say this
because we co-host a podcast together
the
verdict podcast we're gonna have some
new episodes of that coming out soon i
don't just say this because he's a
friend of mine
he destroyed the libs yesterday
i don't know how else to put it there
there were two hearings there was the
gun hearing but then
he also had to go in to talk about s1 or
hr1
it's the corrupt politicians act that
huge election power
power grab that the democrats are
pushing right now so he's going in
between
both of these hearings and just knocking
down
their arguments it's very very important
because the democrats have a lot of
power right now it's the only power that
we have
as this legislation goes through is to
expose
every aspect i think the democrats want
to pass this stuff without anybody
seeing what's really in it
and senator cruz is spelling it all out
right in front of them
for the tv cameras to put a lot of
political pressure because this is all
going to come down to
two senators joe manchin and and kirsten
cinema
the two somewhat moderate democrats who
will decide whether or not to get rid of
the filibuster who will then
that that decision will then decide
whether or not
we're going to have a radically
different political order
if you want to protect yourself from all
these
sorts of things and most notably from
people who are at your front door you've
got to check out ring
so much is going on at our front doors
these days obviously this has
increased for me if someone's stopping
by if something's going on outdoors
even if someone doesn't ring the bell
you will be able to see and speak to
whoever's out there
with ring ring allows you to do that
whether you're in your office whether
you're
in your bedroom whether you are on the
other side of the world
ring has hassle free easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras
you will never miss a visitor some
visitors will be welcome
some will be unwelcome and it helps for
you to know i really recommend it makes
me feel safe
when i'm on the road i know sweet little
leasing cute little junior protected
makes a great housewarming gift for my
friends
because it's super cool and great and
not very expensive so you get credit for
a good gift you don't have to spend a
lot
don't wait get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com knowles
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to start your
ring experience go to ring.com
knowles what is that web address that is
ring dot com
slash knowles can w l e s
senator cruz knocked down a lot of the
gun arguments at the gun hearing he then
goes across the street
shows up to the corrupt politicians act
hearing this is
a major major power grab here and
the way it's being pushed is it's a way
to protect
minority voters against the evil
jim crow racist
regulations such as requiring an id to
vote
voter id that's good that's what this
law would do is say
states are not not allowed to have voter
id laws they're going to say states are
not allowed to ban murderers from voting
states are not allowed to ban child
rapists
from voting states are not there's so
much in this law
and senator cruz hit on i think the part
that
politicians are most excited about the
law would give
politicians a lot of money you know as
the american people think of needy
populations
in need of assistance i have yet to
encounter
a single constituent in texas or in any
of our
states that considers politicians
anywhere near the top of the list
this bill in addition to being the
corrupt politicians act is also the
welfare for politicians act
because this bill creates a matching
program for politicians
not just an even matching program a six
to one
matching program of federal funds
flooding
into federal elections your constituents
in every one of your states i'd venture
do not want to give your campaigns or my
campaigns
millions of dollars of federal money
we don't need welfare for politicians
and i urge you to support
senator blent's amendment the matching
funds is pretty amazing it's six to one
so it's six to one of donations under a
certain amount of money so six to one of
small dollar donations
senator cruz did the math yesterday and
it turns out he would be the number one
recipient
in the senate or in that room rather and
uh
and he would receive 24 million dollars
from the government
but all these guys would receive
millions and millions of dollars
does that seem like the sort of law that
that is
above board a law where the senators are
legislating that they get
millions and millions of dollars of your
taxpayer money i don't think so
he also went out and called the bill jim
crow 2.0 and that's getting a lot of
play
because they're saying is they're
looking at it through a racial lens but
what was jim crow yes jim crow had a
racial component obviously
but the purpose of jim crow was not just
to be a meanie to people of a different
race
the purpose of jim crow was to keep
democrats in power
democrats are the party of jim crow the
point of it was to make sure that there
was no threat to democratic political
rule and that is the point of
of the corrupt politicians act and one
other way they're doing it's not just
that they're taking money
it's not just that they're from
taxpayers it's not just that they're
enfranchising people who should not vote
it's not just that they're taking away
voter id measures
it's that they're also registering
millions of
illegal aliens to vote if this law
passes
millions and millions of illegal aliens
will be registered to vote
and the democrats are going to tell you
that that is not the case
but there's a little hidden provision in
that law that proves that that is
exactly what they're doing and they know
that that's what they're doing
i believe it is the intent of this bill
to register to vote
millions of illegal aliens for the
purpose of diluting the vote of american
citizens and making it harder
for the people to vote democrats out of
office this bill right now
automatically registers to vote anyone
who interacts with the government
so if you get a welfare check if you get
an unemployment check
if you get a driver's license you attend
a public college or university you're
automatically registered to vote
millions of illegal immigrants fall into
those categories
if democratic senators vote as i think
most people expect against this
amendment
it makes clear that their objective is
just what any ordinary person reading
the bill would think their objective is
which is to register millions of illegal
immigrants to vote illegally
because they believe it benefits them in
a political and partisan manner
it obviously does benefit the democrats
in an illegal and partisan manner if
illegal aliens get registered to vote
there are just a lot of polls on this
that that illegal aliens and
particularly immigrants from
latin america vote overwhelmingly and
identify overwhelmingly with the
democrats that's just the way it is i
know ronald reagan said
that hispanics are republicans they just
don't know it yet
well we're still waiting you know that
was what 1982 that he said that and
we're still waiting on it
it hasn't happened democrats know this
and they're trying to exploit this
in the bill the
democrats would give amnesty to
illegal aliens for voting
so the illegal aliens who do vote would
not be held
legally accountable for voting illegally
which is an admission that the law will
register to vote millions of illegal
aliens if the law is not going to
register millions of illegal aliens then
good you don't need to worry about
giving them amnesty when they vote
but they know what this what the effect
of this is going to be and they don't
want to hold their own illegal voters
accountable for doing their bidding
so they're going to let them off the
hook as well
and then finally finally in our fan
girling here
of ted cruz i'm no one can ever tell him
that i was this nice to him on the show
but he did it he was so great yesterday
he was like the only senator
actually senatoring there's a lot of
senators go out there and they what do
they shake hands and they smile and they
pat people on the back
but senator cruz was actually senatoring
yesterday introducing lots of amendments
knocking down the arguments in this bill
getting it all out there in public
and he ripped up the democrats
ridiculous
lie that they're not for defunding the
police you know you and i are old enough
to remember
the past year or more than a year when
democrats have been shouting from the
rooftops that they want to defund the
police
well now they're trying to run away from
that position and because the the left
controls the media and controls the
institutions of communication and also
now controls the government they think
that they're going to be able to get
away with it cruz says
no before you leave uh senator cruz i
might just take this occasion to correct
a couple of the misrepresentations in
what you just said first of all so far
as i know no member of this committee
and members of the senate on
this side of the aisle are in favor of
defunding
the police that is a massive distortion
you just said a moment ago that no
democrat favors abolishing the police
if that were the case why did every
single democrat vote to confirm vanita
gupta
a nominee for the number three position
at the department of justice who said
last year in writing in written
testimony before this senate
advocated abolishing the police and she
was confirmed by one vote
every single democrat was the necessary
vote to confirm a radical
who advocated abolishing the police and
just this week we're taking up kristen
clarke another radical
who has last year in testimony before
the senate advocated abolishing the
police if you don't support
abolishing the police why do you keep
voting for nominees who advocate
abolishing the police
so totally knocks it i mean you'd also
just have to play clips
of every prop virtually every prominent
democrat politician
either implying that they would go along
with this defund the police nonsense or
that they
actually want to defund the police and
why do the democrats want to
defund the police rather why do the
leftist activists want to defund the
place because the police
are the physical representation of our
system of justice here and
the left wants to totally upend our
system of justice they want to totally
revolutionize it
so that they can implement their own
perverse standards
a process that i described at length in
my upcoming book speech list controlling
words controlling minds which is
available now for pre-order pre-orders
doing great so you can pre-order it on
amazon
but you can also pre-order a signed
first edition copy the book is at the
printer now
it is out of my hands no more edits will
be made and it will be in your hands
very soon but only if you
pre-order the the defund
the police line has gained
a lot of traction you've got to give
colin kaepernick credit
you do because what started with
some jerk football player
disrespecting our country and
disrespecting the flag
is now ending up in legislation it's
ending up being parroted by very
prominent politicians even if at the
at this moment they want to run away
from it because crime is spiking
this has become mainstream the calls to
defund the police have become mainstream
and a lot of it goes back to colin
kaepernick taking that knee
disrespecting the star-spangled banner
well colin kaepernick is back in the
news because
of what we are told as a grave injustice
tim tebow a football
player former football player former and
future football player
is back in the nfl after many years away
but colin kaepernick just can't catch a
break he's being persecuted
for his skin color he's being persecuted
for the his systemic historical
oppression he's being
he's actually being persecuted because
he's a big jerk and people don't like
him very much
because he says things that are very
offensive and wrong
uh but this this story i think
shows you the tebow colin kaepernick
issue
shows you the big divide in america and
why we're really talking past one
another
and why there's there's unfortunately
very little hope of coming together
until we can all get on the same page
about what we even believe in this world
about our place in this world
and our place in this country and who we
are ourselves
ben is going to be talking about how joe
biden is
jimmy carter's revenge he is it is weird
we got the gas shortages we got problems
in the middle east
uh so you can go check that out on ben's
show also you may have noticed
that uh uh today our country is feeling
less
free there's lockdowns there's cancel
culture there's all this kind of stuff
well i'm not the only one with a book
out ben also has a book coming out
uh not so long after my book so go check
that out the book is called the
authoritarian moment that's actually
going to be my campaign slogan when i
run
knowles 2024 the authoritarian moment go
check out ben's book as well we'll be
right back with a lot more
tim tebow gets to play in the nfl again
colin kaepernick does not
uh tim tebow is signed now with the
jaguars after being away from the nfl i
guess he's been away from playing in the
regular season for nine years now
but he was briefly back in the nfl or
something six years ago
i don't know you can tell i'm not the
biggest football fan which i think
perhaps gives me a little more
perspective on this thing
because there's an image that's going
around the internet it's colin
kaepernick taking a knee
and it's tim tebow taking a knee they
both did the same thing on the field
so how come one of them gets to play
again and one of them is not in the
in the nfl well people will argue well
kaepernick's not that good at qb and
then
people will argue teemo is not that good
but actually tim tebow's going to play a
different
different position now and maybe colin
kaepernick couldn't do that
the left is arguing that tebow
and kaepernick are doing the same thing
they're both taking a knee on the field
and the only reason that kaepernick
is not allowed back in is because he's
black and tebow's white
the right is pointing out that yes
physically
tebow and kaepernick do the same thing
on the field
but the meaning of what they're doing is
totally different
tim tebow is taking a knee in gratitude
to god
that is that and it's this is not
ambiguous he's been very open about this
that is the meaning of his of this
symbol of what he's doing
kaepernick is taking a knee to
disrespect
the star-spangled banner which is the
flag
which is the symbol of the whole country
and he pretended for a little
bit that he was just protesting police
brutality or whatever that is
but he's not because then when he became
the face of nike sneakers
he was able to nix a product that was
going to come out with the betsy ross
flag
so not just the current american flag
but the revolutionary american flag
i don't think police brutality was a big
issue in 1776
but obviously the object of colin
kaepernick's protest is not just
the cops you know they beat up what was
that guy's name rodney king
30 years ago it's not just that it's
he's protesting the cops as a symbol of
the justice system as a symbol of the
country
and his his real issues with the country
which he says is systemically racist
and intrinsically unjust and that's why
he wants a revolution
people like the guy who's humble and
respectful and
gives thanks to god people don't like
the jerk
spoiled brat pinko who hates his own
country
and and therefore his countrymen
this is not complicated these are
totally different things
but in the left's confusion over what
this symbol means you
you see the source of so much of their
confusion what the left is seeing here
is only the physical
the left thinks that the physical
predominates everything
so it's skin color most notably right
skin color is the reason
that it's how we can explain everything
in the entire world it's just based on
skin color and white supremacy
or sex you know women are oppressed
because of their
physicality because of their bodies or
the transgender issue
which is that the physical is so
important
that even if someone believes on the
deep metaphysical level
that they're a woman and they think that
their their real
body has no nothing to do with who they
really are right so in that sense you
have the denial of the physical
but you you actually can become the
other sex
just by mutilating yourself and getting
some surgeries or putting on a dress or
some
lipstick and stilettos that if you if
you
do change the physical then there is no
question that
that is who you really are and you see
that all this physical stuff
in kaepernick but you see the
metaphysical you see the spiritual and
tebow
he's down there and he's thanking god
he's think this is a a spiritual term
that has a physical representation
if we want to destroy our country we can
only focus on skin color and sex
and resentment and pride
the deadly sins vices and the physical
world to the exclusion of the spiritual
if we want to have a country we can
get rid of the resentment we can get rid
of the pride and we can embrace humility
and gratitude gratitude to god
ultimately but gratitude to
our forefathers who gave us this country
gratitude to the country itself
gratitude to our countrymen whom we live
with
that's the way forward and that's that's
why people like tebow enough to put him
back in the nfl
and even though i have no intention of
ever watching him play i
am pleased to see that there's people
are at least
keeping that little bit of common sense
speaking of being out of a job liz
cheney is about to lose her job
liz cheney is now going to be recalled
as the leader
of the house republican conference so
it's not the top position in house
leadership in the gop but
it's it's still leadership and finally
the actual republican leader kevin
mccarthy
has pulled his support from her she's
about to get recalled
and so she took to the floor to whine
about it
today we face a threat america has never
seen before
a former president who provoked a
violent attack
on this capital in an effort to steal
the election
has resumed his aggressive effort to
convince americans
that the election was stolen from him he
risks inciting
further violence i am a conservative
republican
and the most conservative of
conservative principles
is reverence for the rule of law the
election
is over that is the rule of law
that is our constitutional process this
is not about policy
this is not about partisanship this is
about
our duty as americans remaining silent
and ignoring the lie emboldens the liar
i will not participate in that i will
not sit back
and watch in silence while others lead
our party
down a path that abandons the rule of
law
and joins the former president's crusade
to undermine
our democracy saint liz making her final
stand
beginning with a lie she's saying that
president trump incited
a violent insurrection you can play the
clips from the day
president trump very clear be peaceful
be peaceful don't be violent be peaceful
as for the insurrection what did the
insurrection amount to it killed capital
police officers no it didn't
it didn't that was a lie that was a lie
pushed by the mainstream media
well people did die that day that's true
one of the trump supporters died was
killed by capitol police that's it
that's who died in the political
violence well
they almost took over the government no
they didn't they didn't almost take over
the government
some guy stole pelosi's podium and
another guy in a horn helmet danced
around on a desk
but they there was there was never any
moment at which
the government was almost taken over am
i am i saying that it's good to go and
right in the capital no
people people should be held responsible
of course
but liz cheney's claim here this we've
never seen anything like this the
violent insurrection is
just so disingenuous
it's it's so i don't even want to accuse
her of being disingenuous here it's
maybe she's just totally ignorant but
it's just wrong leftists burned the
country to the ground for eight months
in 2020. they burned down government
buildings
threatening the rule of law they're
openly calling to defund the police
and abolish the police threatening the
rule of law they burn down private
businesses they threaten individuals
you've got
joe biden and maxine waters
putting their thumb on the scales of
justice threatening the judiciary
maxine waters threatening more riots if
if the judiciary doesn't give these
the mob what the mob wants i just don't
want to hear it i did so
preposterous and liz cheney say i'm a
conservative i'm a conservative
conservative i'm the most conservative
of conservative conservative republicans
and yet
i i didn't vote for the republican
president i tried to impeach him a
couple times probably didn't vote for
him the first time either and i
pretty much only talk to left-wing news
outlets and i back up left-wing talking
points and i constantly throw my own
party under the bus but i'm very
conservative
don't you see i think the final nail in
liz's political coffin
she just won a not so coveted
endorsement
she got the endorsement of i kid you not
o.j simpson
now there's a clip o.j simpson has
actually a very funny twitter feed where
he
posts videos of himself i'm not going to
play it
and the reason that i'm not going to
play o.j simpson's commentary on my show
is that o.j simpson is a double murderer
who got away with his crime and i just
can't bring myself
to to give this guy air time and and
listen to him and look at him on tv
however it is a
telling circumstance that o.j simpson is
endorsing liz cheney here the rule of
law
liz cheney standing up for the rule of
law and defended by um
oh the most infamous murderer alive in
our country right now yes the rule of
law
he endorsed cheney he said
it seems that the big truth and honesty
seems to be the enemy of many of these
republican politicians
and liz cheney stands up for the truth
that's got her a lot of heat
she may lose her position in the party
she may even lose her career as a
politician
but that is something to be admired
standing up for the truth that's
something i know her father wouldn't
have done so he doesn't
oj doesn't like dick cheney uh but right
now i'm kind of a fan of liz cheney
this this liberal talking point that
you're hearing repeated not just by
double murderers such as o.j simpson but
you're hearing it from all the left-wing
talking heads
and you're hearing it from liz cheney
herself is so
grating i can't i hate it i hate it
which is
that liz cheney and the lincoln project
and george bush that's true conservatism
you hear this people who come generally
speaking from the liberal wing of the
republican party that they're the true
conservatives i once had a waiter friend
of mine who
we were pals but he was extremely
left-wing and would get very fired
up and he went he was very angry with me
for supporting trump and he said no
michael look i support true conservatism
you know guys like john mccain let me
tell you about true conservatism
and what it means to them true
conservatism for these people
is basically just refers to
feckless and basically liberal people
and the way that they express themselves
is that you'll hear it all the time from
concerned trolls on the left who will
say look
i i really want there to be a strong
republican party look i i
actually look i don't agree okay i'm not
saying i'm a conservative i don't agree
but
i think it's very healthy for our
country
to have a strong conservative movement
but just not any of the guys who are
effective yeah no
but you know trump or reagan well now
they like reagan because reagan's dead
but when reagan was around they called
him a nazi
and a white supremacist and all the
stuff that they called trump you know
look i
i support i want no you don't want there
to be a strong conservative movement you
don't want there to be a strong
republican party because you think
they're wrong
and you want to beat them and that's
fine we do this on
on the right too we will do this we'll
say look i i think there should be a
strong
liberal liberal faction in this in this
country
but what the left is doing right now
that's not liberal we do it all the time
you know that the libs say
that's not true conservatism and then
the conservatives say that's not true
liberalism
but how about we stop pretending that we
are the experts on our opponent's
ideology
and philosophy how about we do that this
talk
you hear this talking point from a lot
of people on the right and i think it's
kind of disingenuous
the the left they're they betrayed
liberalism they're actually we're the
real liberals and we're the real
conservatives and all the good stuff
that anyone ever likes well that's us
and all the bad stuff that's the other
guy no i
i think that there's a strong argument
to be made that the hard left
is following liberalism to its logical
conclusion maybe there were some
perversions along the way and that's
fine that's an interesting conversation
but
they're they're liberals they're libs
they're they're leftists we're
conservatives
they don't get to define what
conservatism is because they don't have
our best interests at heart and they
don't really know what they're talking
about
and frankly the same can be said of the
other side too i actually go into this
argument at pretty great length
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling lines
which is available now by the way four
for pre-order real conservatism
i was i was just watching the view i
wasn't really watching the view but i
was watching a clip from the view
and megan mccain was interviewing stacey
abrams
and she showed us stacey abrams did
actually megan a little bit too
but stacey abrams showed us what real
liberalism looks like
u.s economy only added 266 000 jobs last
month which was
far less than the more than 1 million
that was expected it was so bad that
there were reporters on air that had to
double check the number
to make sure they had actually read it
correctly not to mention that the fact
that all the jobs
went to men is this a clear indication
that throwing money at this problem
isn't working
actually i would say a different way we
know this is a complicated challenge
a pandemic that's affected the economy
for women in
devastating ways and the notion that
recovery would happen
overnight is just it's unfounded
instead what we're seeing are the
combination of being able to survive the
pandemic
and start to build towards recovery and
i think that's why the american jobs
plan
and the american families plan are both
so incredibly important because it
recognizes that the
economy of care which employs so many
women has got to be seen as an essential
part of how we rebuild our economy
and that it is insufficient for us to
simply focus on the more traditional
masculine areas of
the economy recognizing that we have to
have women in every area but that in
particular women have been hardest hit
and therefore we need intentional
engagement and intervention to rebuild
it back
more solidly this is real radicalism
notice what she says the the
traditionally masculine areas of the
economy
so i guess not not childbirth not
tending a home not raising a family that
we're not focusing on that right no
that's not what stacey means
stacy says we need women in every single
segment of the economy
we need women firefighters we need
women special forces we need women
all throughout the entire economy do you
really believe that
notice even megan is accepting the
liberal premise here even in the
question
i'm sure a lot of conservatives would do
it but megan is showing here she goes
this is outrageous there aren't a lot of
jobs and all the jobs are going to men
so here's a here's a real conservative
point
what if women don't need to work
in the same way that men need to work
what if men and women's relation
to the economy and to society and to the
family and to themselves
is different you're not really allowed
to say that
megan mccain asks this question of
stacey abrams
why is it you know how do we fix this
economy where all the jobs are going to
men
now you'll hear a lot of conservative
actually you heard trump do this trump
would say
look we're so happy black unemployment
is at all time lows you say that's
awesome
and hispanic unemployment is at all time
lows oh great that's cool and women's
unemployment is at all time lows you say
hold on a second first of all women have
always been employed women have always
done a lot of things raising a family is
actually harder work than what men do
it's different and i don't mean to
diminish
what we men do look i go out to the salt
mines every day
and i talk about politics and own the
lips i'm not diminishing the value of
that work but i am just saying i've seen
sweet little elisa do it
the woman hasn't slept in four months
because she's up feeding the child
and we've only got one so far imagine
when you've got multiple kids imagine
when you're attending a home imagine
when you're doing
all that sort of stuff in the home
economy to say nothing of what one does
outside into the community more broadly
and that's even without
taking into consideration formal
employment in a job
do we really believe as conservatives
that that women
should need to work outside the home
that they need to that it's that it's a
positive good and it's bad if they're
not working outside the home
i don't believe that for goodness sakes
betty friedan one of the most famous
feminists in american history didn't
even believe that
there's a very famous exchange where
betty friedan was talking with simone de
beauvoir
both very prominent feminists both were
i guess a little more radical than free
dan
and free dan said look if women want to
work outside the home that's fine but if
they want to stay in the home that's
fine too
and beavoir said nope no way can't you
can't give them that choice
because if women have that choice
they'll stay home
they'll want to stay and they'll wonder
i can't tell you how many letters i get
to this show in the mailbag
saying hey michael i'm in my third
master's degree or whatever and i'm
you know i've got to go get this job and
my boyfriend you know he might move
but should i follow him i really just
want to raise a family and get married
but
my whole society is telling me i've got
to go work for some other guy at the
widget factory in middle management
until i'm 40 and then maybe i can have a
kid and you just think
stop listening to these idiots in the
popular culture
and in in the academy and who are
cultural revolutionaries
who are trying to ruin your life don't
do it it's perfectly natural if you want
to stay home raise a family have
children
attend a home that's good it's a good
thing
imagine sweet little alisa's been gone
for the past few days i'm living in
squalor
i'm living like a pig and slop right now
in my home
because because men and women are
different all right enough of that
speaking of women who are excellent
not just you know not not just in the
terms of the natural feminine
you know virtues and women who a woman
who works from her home
but also a woman who has a lot of
political power
the queen of england queen of england
read the queen's speech
yesterday and she really i think upset
the libs
because she sort of
came out in support of voter id
legislation will be introduced
to ensure the integrity of elections
my ministers will promote the strength
and integrity of the union
okay so she's reading the thing is she's
not just reading her own
words as though this were some cree
decor that we need voter id she's
reading the
policies of the conservative relatively
conservative government
that that's there but of course it's
common sense everyone supports voter id
majorities of every demographic support
voter id
but the libs want to tell you it's jim
crow 2.0 completely ridiculous
and then when they can't defend that
assertion they'll go out and say
that conservatives they're not just
racist bigot terrible people
they're traitors president biden said
there's a mini revolution
going on in the republican i mean uh
it's a mini civil war going in the
republican party
chuck the civil war is over uh and the
conservatives have lost
and they've lost to they've lost a
tribalist and they've lost a tribalist
who want to promote a big lie so what
and so we got to break down what is the
big lie
because we talk about the big lie all
the time but what is fundamentally the
big lie the big lie is promoting
something
that undermines democracy that actually
says that
the the the will of the american people
is is sort of throughout the world of
the the american people and it's
fomenting sort of you know attacks on
our government right now we're at sort
of
nationals our greatest national security
threats are actually from
this this full meaning of of these lies
so there becomes something there's
something
bigger at stake here than just just
partisanship
you know with all this talk about civil
war i i think that you know ulysses s
grant at the start of the civil war said
there are but two parties now
traders and patriots i'm afraid chuck
that we're we're increasingly
coming back to that time i i i fear
cornell uh that myself so ridiculous
if if you didn't see this clip the man
who is speaking for most of that is a
grown man wearing a pinstripe suit with
pink collar and a purple shirt with a
white collar and a very loud
tie and he's asking to be taken
seriously on a news program and he is
being taken seriously by chuck todd on
nbc
when he says that the gop they're the
party of traders because of the big lie
and the will of the people
all i will say on this is obviously look
the election is what the election is joe
biden is the president of the united
states there's no there's no denying
that
for republicans who have concerns about
voter integrity
it is not unreasonable to have
questions about a process that involved
the upending
of major election integrity laws that
involved the expansion
of things like drop boxes or even
election day itself
that did not did not have the
traditional safeguards and that in some
cases in the case of pennsylvania
notably
uh involved violating the state
constitution
on on election law it's not unreasonable
to have questions about that you're not
a traitor if you have questions about
that
if anything the people who who keep
pushing the big lie of the big lie or
whatever you know the lie of the big lie
and the nazis and the traitors and you
know all this kind of
ridiculous rhetoric from the left if
anything their
insane protestations of this make me
very
skeptical that that they're uh they're
particularly concerned about art
democracy
and voter id and anything like that uh
the erosion of faith in our institutions
is
what is at the heart of this this is why
people keep questioning the elections
this is not something the republicans
started this has been going on for a
long time
don't forget the republican the
democrats rather wouldn't accept the
results of the 2000 election
the democrats wouldn't accept the
results of the 2016 election
and there were far fewer questions in
those elections it was those years
2000 and 2016 were far uh less unusual
than than 2020 in in large part because
of the virus and the lockdowns and the
upending of our economy and the changing
of a lot of these laws
so this broader forget about 2020 for a
second the broader problem of
not having faith in the institutions
that's a real threat here and when you
look at other countries that descend
into absolute chaos i'm thinking of our
friends over in the middle east right
now
you do fear that a lot of this is
because people do not have respect
for the rule of law do not have respect
for national borders do not have respect
for the country
itself and you see those problems
festering here and they are being
encouraged
almost exclusively by the left
is there anything we can do it about
that or are we just going to descend
into the norm for for the rest of the
world
which doesn't look so pretty i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show